hello i guess we're on here we're live
now i think i should have
my
um
i guess it isn't there yet
the uh yeah i also like to
check this out on
my ipad so that i can answer questions
so today
as we continue our 90-day challenge and
i
share these
moments with you as i talk about my
experience of learning uh
persian and arabic
and talk about language learning in
general
and share ideas with you uh today i want
to talk about you know what is the best
time to study what is the best time to
study languages
and talk to you a little bit about when
i study languages and of course i'm
interested in hearing from you when you
study languages
all right
so
um
i was thinking about this last night
because
at night
when i study
um i am more likely to be tired more
likely to feel i'm not getting anywhere
uh more likely to feel frustrated
uh
feel that i've kind of hit a wall
the language doesn't seem fresh to me
anymore
and yet in the morning
when i open up my ipad and do a lesson
on lincoln persian or arabic or even if
i grab one of my books i don't have an
example here now
the language is fresh i'm curious it's
it it feels good to be back at it again
so uh you know right off the bat i would
say that in my own experience
mornings
are better than say 10 o'clock at night
just in terms of my my brain being more
receptive
and i wouldn't be surprised if there's
research which shows i'm just going to
finish my d here
wouldn't be surprised if there's
research that shows
that um our brains are you know to the
extent that they can measure these
things are more receptive to new new
ideas that that the neurons are firing
more actively in the morning than they
are at night i just don't know that but
i know that's been my own experience and
i should say that
even when i was in business if i had a
major problem to resolve or we had a
a big issue or customer you know there
was a big claim on some lumber or
supplier wasn't delivering or
any major problem the worst thing you
can do is to look at it at night
because everything looks better in the
morning
and everything is terrible at night
and uh if you go to bed with the problem
it can even affect your sleep
so if i uh if i saw an email or a
message that indicated that there was a
problem and i happened to look at it at
eight or nine o'clock at night i didn't
touch it
uh until the morning and in the morning
i would find solutions so this was no
longer just a problem
it was a challenge and i could find
solutions for it so i think um
you know i think this is uh applicable
to language now for some reason i don't
seem to have
i was going to check this with uh let me
just see on my ipad here
um
go away call from mr deloitte
call from miller deloitte
so
um yeah so i think let me just see if i
can find this here because i like to get
your questions
and uh it doesn't seem to be up here
um
and let's go there
and go to youtube see i have my ipad
running beside me
and uh so
and there we go
okay now i've got it up here now all
right
it's coming i think all right so there's
the question
when do you guys like to study
for now i gotta
also i have to
okay
there we go and i've muted it so there
we go so now i should point out that
while mornings are great
uh i don't just study in the morning so
if i
go to the gym at five
then i'll be listening
um
so that and listening of course is also
a big part of studying so right now for
example i have this story in
persian about amir khabib who is a very
famous person in the history of iran
and i'm listening to it i've listened to
it quite a few times and there's a lot
of new vocabulary for me there
and i find that if i listen to it uh a
few times it makes it easier for me to
read when i read it again i look up new
words
particularly because
um
in uh in farsi in version we don't have
text-to-speech and with all of its
faults text-to-speech is a great help
in learning a language all right
so there is the uh subject matter now
for some reason this doesn't show that
the chat box i'm gonna have to get
sorry uh here we are all right
now we're getting somewhere let's just
have a look here
uh
okay now we're up all right all right
okay now let's so i've just launched
that
and let's see what sorts of reactions we
get how is everyone learning blah blah
blah what language
happy scribe for hebrew and i must say
it works rather well says mark chavez uh
okay happy scribe
uh this has to do with these auto
transcription services
and uh i discovered these i sent two
examples the one vulcalmatic and
happyscribe to uh mark my son
and he and some of the others in the
office tested them and they found that
happy scribe was better than vocalmatic
for italian
and so i'm gonna go back to happyscribe
by the way it's very strange because
happy scribe when i contacted them and
said you do right to left they said no
but then i and the first time i put up
my uh
arabic podcast it wouldn't do it right
to left but the second time it did it in
fact right to left now mark says he's
doing it in hebrew
so obviously it does do it right to left
uh so i really i mean this is
to my mind this is a phenomenal
breakthrough i'm straining from my
subject of when i study but
i have spent a lot of my own money to
transcribe
in romanian in greek in ukrainian
uh in arabic
and uh in persian
and now for much less money i go to
something like happyscribe
and like i think it's ten dollars a
month i get an hour or something that's
enough that keeps me busy or i can go up
to thirty dollars
and then i can transcribe a whole bunch
of stuff so
because we have this tremendous array of
podcasts radio programs audio material
that we can find on the internet and all
of the languages that we are studying
uh the idea that we can for a relatively
reasonable amount
get uh
transcripts that are actually quite
accurate
and the transcripts come with date
stamps and so we are also exploring
whether we can integrate the date stamps
with the audio
uh in a lesson at link no
there's problems because if the podcast
is longer than
say the amount the length of a lesson at
link then of course the audio goes into
a second lesson but you're not gonna
split yeah you may want to go to the
trouble of splitting the audio up to
match the lessons but these are some of
the things that we're looking at there's
always new things
in um language learning i should point
out that eric of our office tested uh
happy scribe for japanese he said it was
very good and mark tested it for a very
fast uh exchange in italian and it was
also very accurate so automatic
transcription is here try happy scribe
and you can turn your favorite listening
material into lessons that you can study
at link
[Music]
okay cause i was wondering if you were
canadian i'm canadian and they suck at
speaking french over here you can visit
everything blah blah blah so there's a
lot of background steve i study first
thing in the day i wake up at 5 30
and read after breakfast i don't know
i've actually listening okay so yeah
early in the morning
is better so see
mark i enjoy studying
and maybe another hour in the evening
and evening i study much less
intensively yeah that's been my
experience i don't mind studying in the
evening and an evening would be maybe a
good time to do something that's not too
demanding like watching a video if if
you find a video on netflix that's in
spanish and you're studying spanish so
that the more intensive learning it
seems to be other people agree is better
to do it
in the morning
mateus also agrees if you try to
recently fall asleep
uh here is your preferred deuce on the
morning but i get dropped work six a.m
don't get home until five to seven pm
and then i'm exhausted
that's the problem the only advantage is
that if we consider that uh listening is
a part of language learning so if you go
to work at early in the morning whether
you're in your car or on a train unless
there's too much ambient noise in the
train or bus
that is also
a time to
study
oh t-shirts okay i keep on forgetting i
gotta bug the office on t-shirts
uh okay how would you learn the japanese
writing system well the japanese writing
system
of course it consists of three
in effect three writing systems there's
the chinese characters in japanese known
as kanji and there's the hiragana and
katakana
so hiragana and katakana as many of you
know
are two parallel
syllabaries so each sound represents a
syllable
the syllable in other words combining a
consonant and a vowel
and
they're used like the katakana is
typically used for loan words or
uh onomatopoeia in other words words
that represent the sound like crash or
something
um
and those are relatively easy to learn
because there's only 50 of them the
disadvantage with the katakana is it
doesn't appear so frequently and
therefore
you more quickly get comfortable in
hiragana and katakana takes longer
how do you learn them you just learn the
symbols and do a lot of reading
as with learning arabic or any sort of
alphabet or syllabary where a limited
number of symbols reappear and reappear
reappear
after an initial period of kind of
getting a sense of what the symbols
represent
then the more you read
and even the more you write and that's
why i found with arabic and even when i
did a little bit of hebrew
using the dictation function as one of
the review activities at link where you
hear
a word or a phrase and then you have to
type it in
and
i found that very useful to get a better
sense of what those symbols mean say
with greek
particularly where in some of these
older languages the same sound can have
three or four different symbols
representing it that's not an issue in
japanese
so i would do the dictation function at
link in order to practice the katakana
hiragana
when it comes to kanji you know i
learned kanji a long long time ago i
developed my own system this was before
there were any
computer
systems to help you uh i wrote them all
by the first in fact i wrote them all by
hand i had to write the first thousand i
made a specific effort to learn them
using
flash cards and sort of a primitive
space repetition system after the first
thousand
and encountered a new um you know
character i would write it out by hand
uh i had to i mean part of our
assignment was to write things in
chinese translate things into chinese so
i had a lot of practice in writing now i
don't know whether writing is essential
to learning the chinese characters or
the kanji in japanese
but that's what i did so there may be
better ways of doing it today but to
learn to write and to read in japanese
you need to cover the kanji at least 2
000 of them and people say there's the
toyo you know the most commonly used
kanji but all kinds of kanji that are
not in the
2000 most common kanji appear often
enough in newspapers and books that you
kind of
need more than that in my experience
so much for japanese writing and reading
okay
oh
no
happy scribe was good even for japanese
yeah eric exactly
and which language did you plan to learn
in the future
okay well you know i i don't like to
make commitments too far forward because
basically i'm retired i do what i want
so right now i'm motivated to learn uh
persian and arabic
and i kind of feel i'd like to learn
turkish next because that makes like a
tidy geographic and in a sense cultural
group so that'll keep me busy for a
while i mean i was four or five years on
russian before i expanded even to czech
or ukrainian or polish so you know
there's no hurry the languages aren't
going anywhere
uh i think that'll be quite a lot for me
for the next couple of years and i would
like to improve my korean i would like
to go back in and work on some of the
languages that i took to a certain level
and like to get them sort of over the
hump
so to speak uh and then i will look at
whatever it might be indonesia might be
swahili i have a very good friend one of
my hockey playing playing buddies in
vancouver
uh who was in kenya
as a teacher many years ago and he has a
lot of friends there and we have talked
about trying to get some swahili content
for link and if we get uh swahili at
link i might learn swahili uh maybe in
preparation for going to africa i have
never visited uh africa i mean south of
the sahara so
time will tell we will see i might get
interested in something totally
different too
oh
okay i want to keep studying japanese
but i have no motivation at all
if you have no motivation how can you
say that i want to keep studying
japanese but i have no motivation well
then you don't want to study japanese
if you kind of at some level feel you
want to learn some language but you're
lacking motivation you have to find
something in the culture that motivates
you
so um
you know it could be a
tv program it could be music it could be
anything you have to find something or a
friend there has to be something that
brings motivation into it because
without the motivation you simply can't
force yourself it's like pushing on a
rope so find some way to motivate
yourself or do something else
do you ignore proper names latin or
greek origin or dominant or do you
ignore the words which don't exist in
the language you are learning
okay
i guess this refers to
what what i choose to save in link or
what i choose to
give myself credit for as a known word
uh i would say that
if i come across a name
then i ignore that so that i remove that
from my statistics
uh but uh
later greek origin words those i count
as known words if i acquire them in a
new language i mean there are always
loan words in in persian there are loan
words from arabic
in
slavic languages there are loan words
from french or from or nowadays from
english so they all count
okay how did you go with speaking with
your dinner party oh yeah yeah it it
went fine i uh you know limited uh
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
anyway forget it i did fine
oh no uh
what do you think about studying chinese
at university along with a degree in
something else yeah but
remember when you're studying at
university that's that might be the
stimulus it's a place where you get
together with other students it's where
you get together with the teacher or
you know you're led to different
resources you might be stimulated about
chinese culture but fundamentally you
have to learn it on your own so
if you are at university and you have
the time
why not do chinese but make sure you put
the effort in outside the classroom as
well
ahmed here is arabic an obstacle for you
it's not an obstacle it's an opportunity
but it's difficult i have to say arabic
is more difficult than farsi or persian
it's more difficult because the uh the
grammar is more complicated
uh
i shouldn't say more complicated but
it's more different whereas persian is
an indo-european language so that it's
the patterns are more
comfortable more familiar whereas in
arabic uh the patterns are new to me and
so
the brain obviously is going to have an
easier time with patterns that are
familiar uh the writing system is also a
little more
the connection between what's written
and how it's pronounced is less
systematic than it is in farsi so i'm
finding arabic difficult
however
you know it's fun i i i go to podcast
from al jazeera or franz van gaal
i get them transcribed by happy scribe
and i fight my way through them and
slowly
you know words like intihabat elections
or uh whatever
you know that are relative you know that
are reappear in these in these uh
lessons they're gradually becoming uh a
part of my vocabulary and i'm enjoying
it
uh okay if you're studying two languages
better start with your weak language or
strong language okay
um
again i don't know um i started arabic
first
and then
started doing uh persian persian is a
lot easier than arabic uh
so for example
for simple conversation i can probably
converse more comfortably easy easily in
persian
but if i listen to a political podcast
in arabic i understand more of it than i
do of the
farsi
so
i think you have to explore that
and i think i wouldn't again do two
languages i'm doing it now for the
purposes of this
90-day challenge
but in fact i want to like if i start
the week in arabic and then i go all
right now i have to switch to farsi
because i have my tutor and stuff i kind
of don't want to leave the one in order
to go to the other at first i thought it
helped to keep things fresh
but after a while as you get into it
more and more you realize that you
actually need to spend the time so
i wish instead that i hadn't committed
to doing two languages
that i could focus on the one on the
other hand at the end of the 90 days i
will have a certain level in both
languages so
you know you've got to decide that for
yourself
okay is it better to study your
listening
losing focus or retention okay when it
comes to listening if i sit down and i
say not going to listen to farsi or
something
i can do it i lose focus if
i'm cleaning up as i did after breakfast
which is why i was a minute or too late
because we had a late breakfast this
morning
you know
international women's day
uh
while i'm doing stuff i actually focus
better because i i don't know what it is
but if i can keep myself busy exercising
driving even though i'm focusing in and
out i'm able to stay with it
uh you know it reminded me the other day
there's this apparently there's this
japanese woman
kondo out here dennis who has been very
successful helping people you know tidy
up their houses their homes
and her thing is to make them like their
clothes so they want to fold them neatly
and they want to clean up and stuff like
that and that then gets people to enjoy
the task of tidying up i have no trouble
tidying up i mean i'm not very tidy by
nature but if i have to go in and tidy
up
i don't mind doing it because i'm
listening i'm listening to my language
while i'm doing it i don't mind cleaning
up the dishes i don't mind uh sweeping
cleaning dusting vacuuming
we have a quiet vacuum cleaner uh
because i can do it while listening
uh is
is it some
here's some word from google translate i
said earlier here from audiobook is it
same okay
you know the uh text-to-speech is
not good
okay
it's not as comfortable to listen to i
couldn't listen to solid text to speech
i can't like al jazeera has text to
speech on their website i can't listen
to it but for one word or one phrase
particularly where you have trouble
pronouncing as in arabic or persian you
have trouble reading it's very helpful
but i i but when i go through my lessons
at link
i have the the natural audio like in in
persian where there is no texas page i
have the natural audio so i listen and i
go to sentence mode in links i'm only
looking at one sentence i listen to the
audio i use the the you know the
loop back five second repeat and i go
repeat and repeat and repeat more or
less where that sentence is
then i move on to the next so i'm much
more comfortable listening to the
natural audio and
the other thing too is we have to
connect emotionally at some level to
what we're listening to
and that's why not only is it important
it's much better to listen to the
natural voice it's also better to listen
to a voice that you like
uh because you gotta connect to it it's
gonna have resonance and text to speech
doesn't have that so text-to-speech has
a limited function but it in
nevertheless very very important in my
experience
okay
kanji is the hardest part of japanese
yep
what is your favorite chinese book
well i mean the book that was
quite fundamental for me
is uh
which is the you know rickshaw boy
written by uh
lausa because i read that after about
seven or eight
months of learning chinese it took place
in beijing
i was in hong kong
the idea of china was still sort of a
romantic place i'd read about the
the 20s and the 30s and the warlords and
the
japanese war and here's this beijing
that
30 years earlier was part of the qing
dynasty and was now
gradually becoming part of the modern
world and here's the story about life in
beijing i mean i just found that book
totally gripping so i would have to say
that uh by lausa would be my favorite
uh
okay some god first prompted me
to set me weaving in
have you
prompt someone to do something how would
you add
if you had
prompt someone to do something
oh someone present how would you add it
and you're like
well prompt someone to do something
i i don't i must say
or if you had learned prompt somebody to
do something how would you add it in
your link i don't understand the
question i must admit
hi from thailand
hi
i have two
first of all languages
it seems as though you try to search out
large languages with a large speaker
base but what do you think of tagalog
well first of all
you know there are many reasons why you
learn a language
uh
i don't just learn languages with a
large speaker base but i'm somewhat more
motivated to learn those languages but i
have learned czech because my parents
are from czechoslovakia i could never
understand that language i have
you know newspaper articles at home from
my father when he did stuff that was in
the newspaper with his friends they went
mountain climbing or stuff like that and
and i just was motivated there's only 10
million people to speak czech
uh on the other hand there are very
large uh groups of people who speak in
indonesian or bahasa various
flavors of it even tagalog is i don't
know how many speakers but there's got
to be 50 million speakers of the galaxy
i just don't know i don't know the
languages the philippines so it's not
just the number of speakers but
uh it is an influence and one of the
reasons why i didn't continue with
hebrew and went to arabic is because
there's far more speakers of arabic than
there are of hebrew
but tagalog is an important language
spoken in the philippines i'm very
curious to know to what extent tagalog
is similar to say indonesian malaysian
i'm interested in languages period but i
can only focus on one or in this case
two languages at a time
steve i've been reading this every day
for an hour for three months and i find
myself getting lost in long sentences if
i keep reading every day will it sort
itself out i mean
japanese is a bit clumsy that way
because
you know if i contrast french to
japanese like the french they'd like to
say everything very logically and very
cleverly and very elegantly
and whereas the japanese has a different
kind of elegance and it's more that
elegance of the sort of what's you know
not stated or implied
and so it's it's more difficult
but uh everything
everything
even english spelling
it does
it is a part of a pattern of a system
and the more we expose ourselves to it
gradually slowly the brain starts to
sort these things out so you just and
and i would in particular with japanese
i would do a lot of listening because
when we listen we get some momentum very
often you read something and you don't
get the sense of the emphasis the
momentum the meaning whereas you hear
the same thing over and over again you
start to get a sense of how that
language works so i would suggest that
you do a lot of listening uh as well as
reading
uh
okay uh uh no i
thought i have no immediate plans to
learn together
when you say you need useful content to
add a language or link what all does
that entail okay we have said
that if we get the 60 mini stories
translated into any language we'll put
that language up on link so we've got
gujarati
we've got bulgarian these are not
major world languages but if we get the
content if we get that in tagalog if we
get that in uh
whatever language thai we will put it up
oh you do find the chinese man skip from
25 to 31 i will chase zoran on that uh
if you want to learn slovak one day for
whatever reason i would gladly teach you
thank you vincent by the way uh
in preparation for going to bratislava
to the polyglot conference i did work on
some slovak
uh we have the mini stories in slovak
and i was able to buy an audio book for
which i was able to find the ebook and i
imported that into link and so i have a
bit of a sense you know how a yak
becomes ak
and the whole body instead of movie so i
have a sense of uh slovak and i feel i
understand it and in fact i spoke some
we had a meeting there in brazil with a
bunch of people from the local community
that the organizers had arranged and i
managed to say a few words in slovak so
i have the feeling and i did in town in
bratislava i went to shops and i spoke
to lobeck and people seem to understand
me now no doubt my slovak is heavily
influenced by my check or even by my
russian but i communicated and
i certainly i certainly understand it
uh but i thank you for the the offer
and but save that for the future
uh okay hello steve do you know what
pewdiepie people
uh
how to study online how to study on my
own marching i would suggest just go to
link get on the farm talk to people
do you speak in polish um
it you know
you know i'm so confused
if
if i sat down with you for 10 15 minutes
um
[Applause]
movie
um
difficult for me right now
um now steve's posted a few videos in
polish how do we get the mini stories
how can we get the mini stores i don't
know what you mean the mini stories are
available at link in those languages for
which we have them uh you can even
you know you can download them you can
do what you want with them
but insofar as getting many stories in
new languages we need people to
volunteer to help us uh get
them uh
blah blah blah
steve what website did you use that had
audio and text in polish okay first of
all in polish there is a tremendous
website called
real polish dot pl
he has fabulous content along the lines
of the mini stores so first of all you
go there we have the mini stories in
polish at link
and then with polish because i had sort
of russian ukrainian check very quickly
i could read books
and so i went to a site called
publio.pl
and i bought audiobooks for which i
could also find the ebooks and they were
available at that website and then i
imported them into link
that's what i did
uh what websites did you use there's
another i think audio techa a u d i o t
e k a has audio books and i think
possibly ebooks in a number of languages
certainly czech slovak
uh
possibly polish you could check that out
as well
how long does it take you on average to
move on from many stories onto more
interesting and difficult content
uh this depends on the language
uh
[Applause]
you know obviously if you are if you
speak a romance language and you're
going from say italian to spanish or
spanish to french i think you can move
very quickly because
immediately you have the vocabulary with
uh greek was
a little more difficult
with romania not so difficult
with arabic in persian
much much more difficult so
this is all a matter of uh
you know it depends on the language
depends on which language you know
you have to experiment and then you can
move to the more difficult and then come
back again to the many stories to
refresh to give yourself a sense of
confidence and then you charge him again
and try and do some of that harder stuff
steve what would you recommend when
i sentence moving with duolingo sentence
cards in anki should i care about having
a typing function to type in the answer
the english translation well
again i'm not familiar with anki i don't
use anki uh
at link i
only type in the target language and i
use that for you know uh
writing systems like greek or
or uh
no or even to improve my comprehension
listening comprehension
but i type in the target language i hear
it text to speech sometimes better
sometimes worse i type it in that's the
only typing that i've done
um
okay
would you say overall arabic is more
difficult than chinese or japanese
that's so difficult to say
uh that's so difficult to say i would
say that
difficult difficult in different ways
but probably less difficult because to
me the biggest obstacle is always the
writing system if you can get to reading
comfortably
then you can start reading a lot
and reading a lot is going to improve
you quickly
so while the arabic writing system is
still fuzzy for me
i know i have to read a lot more
uh
learning characters is a whole other
order of magnitude of not difficulty so
much as a workload
but uh it's going to depend on
different people what they like to do i
i wouldn't want to answer the question
which language do you most enjoy
speaking and why
i get that question i enjoy them all
it's so much fun to speak in another
language as poorly as i spoke uh persian
i was delighted to be able to speak with
my guests to that couple from iran and
when i go back to vancouver and i go to
a store where they have persian
employees iranians are going to be happy
speaking to them arabic you know there's
a guy i buy my coffee from in vancouver
and the first time i went there i can
speak word of arabic uh i've been there
a few times and was only able to say
merhaba and now i'll be able to speak to
them a little more in arabic and that's
fun
so
arabic grammar also difficult for us
arabs no doubt
um
okay roughly many passive known words
would you say is required to comfortably
read common media okay how many
passively known words to read it okay in
romance language like if you already
know english you have 50
of the vocabulary in roman languages
second of all newspapers are written at
a lower level of difficulty than saying
novels or science textbooks so
newspapers are relatively easy
so i mean but i think that yeah
10 to 15 000 known words
would be a good level
and
certainly at that level
even before then you can start importing
uh newspaper articles into link and
start reading them
this is the advantage over languages
where the writing system is so much more
difficult for us like arabic
it's more difficult to bring in
newspaper articles and you're kind of
fighting your way through every word is
new whereas if it's a romance language
and you speak english you're going to
know a lot of the words
you know be able to recognize them so
yeah 10 000 words
uh
where do you find short bits of audio
material for intensive listening i'm
learning probation so it's a bit harder
to find stuff for it okay i mean first
of all
we keep on talking you know and we have
a virtual assistant who lives in serbia
and i keep on bugging him to create the
mini stories for us and servo creation
uh so that we can get going on it
um but
i mean
if you go to google and put uh now again
i don't know what your level is in
croatian uh but i would first of all
google for in english for croatian
stories croatian whatever and then you
can google in croatian for podcasts you
know political podcasts google croatian
and something will pop up now once you
have the podcast you can then go as we
said earlier to happy scribe and have
these transcribed and now you got
material that you can import into the
link and study
why when we are reading something in the
target language we remember everything
but we leave the book behind we're not
able to talk to ourselves
uh
yeah i mean we forget stuff you close a
book and you've forgotten much about
what was in the book you look something
up in the dictionary you close the
dictionary you forgot the meaning of the
word you just looked up
uh to get from
you know listening and reading to
speaking you've got to start speaking
and when you start speaking you won't
have all the words that you can
understand and you just have to keep
going that's that's the nature of our
brains we we don't have photographic
most of us don't have photographic
memory previewed
[Music]
okay
now how do you study when your partner
doesn't like the language you're
studying i remember you said that you
listed in your car and your wife found
it annoying how do you do it okay first
of all
i cannot listen in the car while my wife
is there she's not gonna listen to
arabic you know on the
car radio while we're going somewhere
that's not gonna work i can't even put
earphones in my ear while i'm with my
wife because you know
you're social you can't just but so
my partner my wife it doesn't really
care what language i'm learning she's
doing her thing and i'm doing my thing
um now
uh
polyglot
i don't know the canal polyglot
do you suggest a learning order
regarding chinese japanese korean
uh
i mean my order was chinese japanese and
then korean korean which is still a work
in progress
um
probably
starting with chinese makes sense
because you have to learn the characters
at some point
and so that would be a good place to
start
but it depends on what other factors
there are like what you're interested in
who your friends are where you're living
so forth hey steve i'm learning arabic
in person as well but i feel that i'm
having trouble progressing forward what
are some or auditory results you would
suggest to help with moving forward
well of course you and i are both
you know
masochists
uh
forcing ourselves to do two at once but
certainly persian online
is a great resource
for
persian and i have imported uh all of
their material into link for my own use
uh with arabic and for both of them i
found the many stories very useful in
fact in arabic we have a lot of good
stuff at link who is she in both arabic
and farsi
uh
arabic i um
bought the assimil book and i had it
transcribed so i have assimilated link
it's not that great i find your story
somewhat silly and
and
yeah very quick progression uh persian
online for farsi is very very good just
google persian online you'll find it
um
what else did i find i you know uh
manuel de la moderne
all these books that i found at various
bookstores i uh
sent the audio file off to a lady in
jordan who transcribed them i now know
that i can do that more cheaply
uh
yeah those would be some of the
suggestions you've got to google a book
i have to google a look
uh if you find any let me know
uh okay i've
been struggling to learn mandarin even
after in taipei for a few months would
you recommend watching children cartoons
in mandarin i mean it's background noise
but
essentially you have to listen and read
you have to learn the characters
to my mind i didn't learn chinese
without the characters but i guess you
can learn without reading i just find
that reading is such a powerful
way to learn
that i would
i would focus more on listening and
reading and nothing wrong with watching
cartoons
in mandarin
uh listen to the sentence and try to
yeah i agree
what is the best non-english text you
have ever read i i don't know how to
answer that question
uh best in what way i've read many
interesting books in swedish and chinese
and french you name it and listen as
well how do you go about learning
language when there are people who mock
you for doing so even in this family i
mean that yeah people uh consider me a
bit of a nut for spending so much time
learning languages i mean that could be
any interest you have people might find
it strange i just ignore those people
uh i try to learn phrasal verbs i don't
know how i should add them as link they
have extra words in a sentence
so i mean what you can do is you just
say the phrase save the phrase you can
tag them as phrasal verbs uh you know do
do save phrases and do use the tag
function then you can re review those
tagged phrases in the vocabulary section
uh 35 people ah steve could you post a
video of your tutor session and then the
report from the tutor
so we can see the structure and type of
tutor we can aim for
uh okay um yeah i could do that i mean
not all the tutors want to be i did
issue like you're not going to listen to
an hour i'm not going to put an hour of
my lesson up uh but i can share with you
uh the report but the report just is a
collection of words and phrases uh in in
the case of persian or arabic uh which i
you know struggled with and i get that
and i get the audio for it so it's not
very difficult just ask your tutor
to make a list of 10 or 15 words or
phrases that he or she noticed that you
struggled with or couldn't remember or
used incorrectly and then to record it
and then that then is sent as a report
within link
i'm 16 to speak around five languages
what career can i pursue with the
languages that's hard to say i mean
i would say that you still need other
skills you can't say i speak five
languages therefore someone will hire me
you have to have something else a
technical or or other skill and then
more opportunities will come your way if
you speak more languages
do you recommend learning the radicals
first to help learning the characters i
found that as with many things that are
explained to us early
uh
that these explanations explanations
don't do much for us and so i thought i
felt the radical explanation didn't help
much until after i had had a lot of
exposure to the characters and i started
seeing the radicals so i would say no i
would say focus on learning the
characters
themselves
and then after a while you'll start to
notice them you can review the radical
thing but don't try and learn all the
radicals i don't i didn't find that
helpful
uh
uh according to your experience it's
probably a polyglot without traveling of
course it is of course it is uh a lot of
the languages that i've learned i
haven't been to the country uh when i
was in china giving uh speeches uh
promoting my book ten or so years ago we
went to some of these uh
universities in china and some of the
students there were so fluent in english
japanese french had never left china
whereas we have chinese immigrants in
canada who have lived in canada for 20
years and can't speak english so
it's entirely up to how hard you work at
at your level of commitment
help me gain total confidence and how on
my
chinese speaking person immigration
about four years ago i am educated and
scored okay so davidson so
yeah i mean uh
total competence let's let's be careful
here total confidence to my mind is what
i would call b2c1 you can talk to
anybody about anything you use so use
the words correctly and remember too
that pronunciation is only a part of how
you come across in the language if you
have an accent but you use words
correctly elegantly you create a very
favorable impression on the listener i
remember my banker a while ago was an
immigrant from switzerland and he had a
very pronounced swiss
accent
and he came to our office one day with
his sidekick who was from england and
the swiss guy with his accent used the
english language much better than his
partner from england so confidence is
about using words correctly and you
achieve that through a lot of listening
and reading a lot of listening and
reading and then gradually you start to
use the words and phrases that you gain
from your listening and reading you
start to use them in your speech and so
very much i think link can help you
achieve that and to do that you should
be bringing into link because you have a
high level already i'm you know
surmising here
bring in
you know audio books literature uh
history books subjects of interest to
you expand your vocabulary listen to a
variety of different things listen a lot
and particularly if you find something
that you like listening to and i've had
this experience in the number of
languages the voice the subject matter
and this kind of penetrates your brain
because it has resonance and all of that
enables you to
improve your level of confidence in the
language so good luck to you david and
please yes you can do that at least will
you be going back to korean before going
on turkish probably
oh and does anyone see these messages
because i'm not sure if yes i see them
yeah i learned german without visiting
germany okay i am educated
but i have difficulty understanding the
news while listening to the radio i have
difficulty totally understanding the
news of the newspapers yes and therefore
you have to in fact get beyond the news
and the newspapers you have to get this
is to davidson you have to get to where
you can read a novel where you can
listen to a novel so
the the bad news i guess is that you
have trouble understanding those things
the good news is that you have
a great
fun time ahead of you
of of uh interacting with interesting
content but you have to find it so
import your newspaper articles in the
link work on the words and phrases
import books into link uh if you are
have audio that you want to work on get
it transcribed and bring it into link
because if you're listening and not
understanding you have to then be able
to read it or else those words will
forever be you know uh non-meaning to
you okay
i cannot i'm learning french for a long
time i can read i listen very well but
no matter how much i try i can't write
in french
well let's start writing write more
write more do it on the internet you can
look words up you can look grammar
points off and start writing
do you think link will have a function
to create a transcription out of
podcasts sorry for your vitamins okay
it's
good uh yeah i mean we're discovering
there's more and more technology out
there so now we mentioned this uh happy
scribe
how we do that i'm not sure i think
initially
for
uh where is this question yeah podcast
so for us to put the podcast into our
library
we need the permission of the
publisher of the podcast
uh particularly if we're going to add
transcript but nothing prevents you
from
going to happy scribe and it's not that
expensive and and getting these
transcribed if we can come up with a way
and we were just talking about this that
we can sort of
integrate podcasts uh maybe we can you
know just as we go to newspaper articles
we uh
you know scrape them as it's called if
we can do that with podcasts and
introduce transcription
maybe but in the meantime until we have
a solution i suggest you go to
happyscribe and get your favorite
podcast subscribe
okay maybe you would like it blah blah
blah it strikes me how difficult you are
when it comes to learning languages
only some results i can hear
as an entrepreneur do you think someone
who speaks a foreign language is more
likely to have a successful career you
think it's just a myth
i mean there's so many things that go
into being
a successful entrepreneur including life
big factor luck however it's a function
of opportunities if you speak more
languages you will have more
opportunities i can tell you that from
my own personal experience but it
doesn't guarantee greater success
i'm discouraged because after searching
around i have no place to actually use
it my mandarin is very close to useful
but i can't use it okay
uh we have to
love the language for the language
itself
and if the opportunity presents itself
you use it
or
if you say okay i want to use my
mandarin then you'll have to go and look
for opportunities to work for a company
that's working in china or go to china
or whatever it might be what's been your
most favorite language i don't have a
most favorite language hi i'm from
brazil steve how are you i agree with
you it has alright john
a very effective language i wish one day
i will okay you know what and i'm very
curious about azerbaijan because
i don't know how different it is from
turkish and of course uh
15 20 of the population in iran speaks
azerbaijani but it's all part of that
part of the world you know
anytime i have a chance to use it as a
trip to china
[Music]
you know i think assimil gets a lot of
favorable press
i'm not a you know it's to me it's just
content uh i find a lot of their
explanations are uh distraction
um
yeah it's okay
uh
la pogea no apogee
yeah i just enjoy doing it i would say
that i've put more effort into learning
languages over the past
uh 10 years than i ever did previously
during my life
and
do you think moses approaches learning
phrases and expanding your vocabulary
daily by talking to people you know to
me this idea that you can talk yourself
to fluency is not very practical
because who you're going to talk to you
can't just go around and bother people
you may find a sympathetic listener
you know you can go into okay i can go
into a korean bookstore and
you know try and speak to the person
there in korean uh until a customer
comes in who wants to buy a book now the
lady uh there has to deal with a
customer you can't bother people
try and think of it the other way if if
as an english speaker if
people came up to you and started
sort of speaking to you in semi english
how much patience are you going to have
for that so to me it's not a it's not a
a real solution
uh
but people do what they like to do
study your target language and you can't
find interesting content you read sub
person okay
finding interesting content is big uh
we're going to put more sort of effort
at link into
improving our library bringing
interesting content to the attention of
people
in arabic and persian i've just looked
around for whatever i could find i found
persian online i googled google in
english google in persian google and
arabic
uh
with polish i described what i did i
found the audiobooks and ebooks
it's everyone has to do that
on their own because everybody's
interests are different
uh okay when we listen do we have to
notice the words or let it go
yeah i just find that we notice more and
more things don't really match steve yes
but i'd like to go back to russia that
was fine uh exchange
okay all right
do you think 30 times applies to chinese
question uh how many words for fluency i
don't know
all right at that point i gotta run so
thank you everyone and uh we're gonna
call it here thank you for listening and
uh send any questions or put additional
comments and questions on directly onto
youtube and i'll answer them there
bye for now